thomas bonjour la grande conférence de
presse de sergueï lavrov débutera dans
peu de temps alors quels seront les
thèmes qui vont être évoquée par le chef
de la diplomatie russe eh bien on
s'attend à une conférence de presse très
dense beaucoup de sujets qui devraient
être abordés lors de cette conférence de
presse qui a un peu de retard
vous voyez les lève le siège de la brp
est toujours vive les journalistes sont
présents dans cette salle de conférence
is attendent le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères qui devrait arriver
ici un peu plus d'une demi heure
maintenant alors parmi les sujets qui
devraient être évoquées lors de cette
allocution du ministre russe des
affaires étrangères il ya évidemment les
dossiers de l'actualité à savoir donc
l'iran déjà et puis aussi la libye et la
syrie des dossiers dans lesquels est
bien la russie a tenté de jouer un rôle
de médiateur évidemment sergey lavrov
devrait aborder en longueur la situation
dans ces pays et puis il pourrait
également abordé la situation en
amérique du sud au venezuela plus
précisément où au cours de l'année
passée
moscou avait dénoncé une tentative de
coup d'état de la part de juan goyer
d'eau peut-être que là encore sergueï
lavrov donnera quelques explications et
puis cette année a évidemment été
marquée par le réchauffement des
relations diplomatiques entre kiev et
moscou avec notamment les échanges de
prisonniers maison ou encore la tenue du
sommet au format normandie c'était le 9
décembre dernier à paris sergueï lavrov
devrait faire un point sur la situation
des relations diplomatiques entre
l'ukraine et la russie on attend aussi
peut-être des annonces concernant la le
rapprochement de moscou avec paris
emmanuel macron et vladimir poutine se
sont rencontrés à de nombreuses reprises
l'année dernière et des rendez vous sont
d'ores et déjà pris pour l'année à venir
puisque au mois de mai prochain emmanuel
macron sera à moscou pour les
commémorations des 75 ans de la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale voilà donc
pour les sujets qui devraient être
abordés dans cette conférence de presse
une conférence qui intervient dans un
moment un peu particulier puisque vous
savez les eu un remaniement ministériel
cette semaine en russie il ya un nouveau
premier ministre depuis hier monsieur
michu steen il a d'ores et déjà dit et
fait savoir qu'il pourrait y avoir des
changements dans la formation du
prochain gouvernement n'attend donc de
savoir si sergey lavrov sera a maintenu
à ce poste en poste de chef de la
diplomatie russe qu'il occupe depuis
très longtemps il a été nommé en février
2004 thomas poney en direct de moscou
merci pour toutes ces précisions